and when you are
already in the field of doing this human
robotic interaction
um you already in the space of thinking
well i'm interacting with this thing
and it's it has some kind of uh ai you
know some kind of a
conscious maybe some kind of wisdom and
it's interacting with me and it really
gets your head
thinking
well
where this thing can lead us um or how
far will it go this interaction with
will go
um and in
when you're getting to to those thoughts
you need to really start thinking about
what is your boundaries or where do you
want to take this technology
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court ventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with c-tech
hello and welcome to 20-minute leaders
we are starting this episode talking
about robots and ethics and then we're
transitioning to looking at how robots
and agriculture are transforming our
everyday lives and those of farmers but
in a byproduct that of the way we
consume food and everything around us
meet michael roizman vida mikhail
received her bachelor's of arts in
communications at the interdisciplinary
center of herzelia she spent two years
as a research assistant and then a
research team lead at the media
innovation lab at idc researching the
field of human robotic interaction her
research on robots and ethics led her to
write a poster paper that was accepted
to the international hri conference
following her degree she was a project
manager in designing the smart home
robot for samsung korea outlining the
different aspects needed to take into
consideration when designing a companion
robot
following that she joined an innovation
program at idc with the goal to create
innovations that solved 21st century
challenges in this program she founded
with her co-founders b hero b hero
increases crop yield through precision
pollination combining sophisticated
machine learning algorithms with low
cost sensors to simulate full output
potential during peak pollination cycles
today mikhail is the vice president
product of blue white robotics a company
that provides numerous autonomous
solutions including the blue white
robotic kit that transforms any tractor
to an autonomous one she is also a
forbes 30 under 30 recipient
i'm i'm really excited to talk to you
about robots how they're intersecting
our life
you are a co-founder of one of the most
incredible companies in the world be
hero which i have the honor of being a
very small part and today you're vice
president of product at blue white
robotics similar space looking at how
robots are changing the way that we
interact with the world around us quite
literally what i think is fascinating is
going back a little bit also to your
time at the idc talking a little bit
about robots and ethics and how this is
playing out to sort of a greater vision
that you have in your own life your own
journey and and after all this whole
show is about this single question of
why do you do what you do and so we're
gonna uncover it together in 20 short
but meaningful minutes so again mikhail
thank you so much for being here
thank you
uh we'll try to do it in 20 minutes i'll
try to do my best to explain
well
take me back to your
your own relationship with with robots
ethics in the world how did this whole
thing come about
so um basically it's idc
uh we have the idc the mila
and i had the great the privilege of
being one of the research assistant
there
and it's it's just fascinating you know
to realize there is a whole world um
that research the field of human robot
interaction so most of us are familiar
with hci which is human computer
interaction and it's actually it's
meaning it means um all the interaction
that we have with our apps uh with our
phone with our uh you know with
computers and then you take it to the
higher level of robots and basically
when people think about robots they
think about i know humanoid robots um
things they see at movies but robots can
be anything that is uh you know hardware
with intelligence it can also be a
handle of a door
um and if you put eyes on something it's
um automatic you automatically makes you
feel something about it so uh all of
this field of understanding that uh
robots are going to be um
more common in our life um made me
to think that the the part that i want
to investigate in research is the is the
part of ethics um
and it really why do you observe that
this is a a worthwhile conversation to
have i obviously i i know it does but
i'm curious to hear
why why is this a pressing matter that
you're going to devote you know time to
thinking about ethics and robots
this is a great question i think that um
you know we're developing technology and
not always
stop to think how it will affect our
life and when you are
already in the field of doing this human
robotic interaction
um you already in the space of thinking
well i'm interacting with this thing
and it's it has some kind of uh ai you
know some kind of a conscious maybe some
kind of wisdom and it's interacting with
me and it really gets your head
thinking
well
where this thing can lead us um or how
far will it go this interaction with
will go um and in when you're getting to
to those thoughts you need to really
start thinking about what is your
boundaries or where do you want to take
this technology um and i just started to
read every article that was ever um
published on on
human robotic interaction in the on you
know with the with the effects of ethics
um and it's just fascinating and i think
that we don't put enough
um
thoughts on the way we build technology
uh taking into consideration the effects
um
of where the technology can you know
develop and how it will affect us
um and it's very complex and can be even
mean in a way if we're thinking about uh
robots uh you know
um going to fight worse for us or
um if we're going to get robots to be
part of our house
of our relationship maybe you know there
are a lot of movies and books um
uh made out of this um but yeah when i
when i was really um investigating this
this field i just realized how we just
run you know
developing the technology without just
stop for a second and ask ourselves the
hard questions uh how will it you know
eventually uh will affect us
yeah i think it's a fascinating
fascinating conversation my personal
specialization within stanford is human
ai computer interaction so i i feel very
much similar similar thoughts and ideas
and you're touching on some really you
know interesting questions consciousness
ethics and stuff like that which is
which is
tremendously important especially as
you're mentioning that the rate of
innovation is is increasing and so you
know we're seeing these technologies
deployed um really you know all around
us today we're not far from robots
getting into wars or robots entering our
house it actually sort of has happened
already without us noticing
mikhail you're taking this more now to
agriculture side first with be hero now
with blue white robotics tell me about
robots and agriculture where did that
come from
so um
my title for that is more of a
technology in agriculture and and even
more technology that will uh that
empowers people so
my take on that or the thing that i feel
passionate about is how we can take
technology and use it for good
um and to empower us and if we're
talking about robots not to replace us
uh which is
automatically what people think when
we're talking about robots uh oh they're
going to replace us so i think that our
mind needs to go to um
to find innovative ways of uh how
technology can empower us so uh in be
hero uh it's an example and also in in
uh blue white robotics so
um
we're talking about food scarcity world
population that is growing um scarcity
of
labor
and
it's a huge problem
and we're seeing the tractors that are
part of the agricultural world for years
and we understand that okay there's no
labor there's not
more agricultural uh fields uh for us to
grow food so we need to find how are we
going to make the the best of every part
that we have we need to really seize the
potential um and it and it leads to the
technology
and we have the tractors and what we do
in the wet robotics is that we put these
kits that can transform any existing
tractor from any from
any manufacturer and transform it to to
autonomous and then you can manage a
fleet of autonomous robots that just run
uh in the farm um there can be more
efficient uh
and and can really uh see the potential
that you wanna that you wanna get uh
from your farm which is i think a way to
find a solution to a huge problem of uh
food scarcity which is also fascinating
what we're trying to do at b hero so so
you're looking so so you're looking at
how do we take existing um existing
machinery
and how do we create
through external forces we're
introducing sort of this autonomous chip
that is going to be able to allow you
know agriculture farmers or land owners
to be able to then manage this
autonomous fleet to obviously be more
efficient than a traditional human right
yes and also uh the fact that you don't
have enough people that want to do this
job right it's great hard for the
farmers to find people that are willing
to work um and then you just see
you know the yields
growing um away because there's not
enough labor in order to take care of
that so
right right a robot doesn't need a to
sleep necessarily right maybe it
overheats sometimes but we can solve
that but it doesn't get tired it doesn't
become less efficient
over time work overnight
um 24 7
which is which is very important because
uh in agriculture you have
uh an important see of the time of when
you do the tasks and the time of day the
season
it's really important to be very precise
in order to get um the best so
so i'd love to take your look from your
own passion and fascination with with
robot human interaction and
transitioning it into specifically what
you're doing with the blue at robotics
so
you know
looking more you know theoretically i
guess on this idea of robots and
agriculture and what bluewood robotics
is doing what what are some of the
really interesting questions that you
need to deal with either as an
organization or yourself in regards to
exactly the questions that you were
researching back in the idc you know
you're introducing this whole new
technology it's changing behavior it's
changing the way the world is working
what are different things that you have
to keep in mind
yeah so first of all um
autonomy
this is something that can make people
get really stressed um especially if
you're a farmer you need to bring this
uh technology this really
state-of-the-art technology into your
own backyard um so it's really important
as a product to be able to um
provide this uh sense of um
you know safety
everything is right with this huge robot
with this huge machine
is okay
and it's in control
and also to make it
as easy as possible because at the end
you want to replace something that
people are used to do for
hundreds of years or maybe um you know
dozens of years and to do it um
uh as simple as possible to you know
just change the tractor from uh a manual
uh
state to autonomous state and to be able
to control a fleet of a few tractor um
as seen seamlessly as as possible and
and it's a huge challenge to do so
how do you
how do you what did you find is most
helpful in gaining quick confidence so
taking somebody who's looking at their
land and saying wow i'm not really sure
that i'm ready for a vehicle to
autonomously operate on my land this is
my livelihood this is my business
how what do you need to do as an
organization to
garner trust amongst you know the
stakeholder here what's been most
effective
so um
it's really important for us to be there
at the field with the clients
we are there with them operating the the
tractors showing them how we are doing
that uh
from within the company um and we are
there in this uh process um and we're
not um
um
you know running to anywhere we are
there to show them to educate them um
and so is it mainly in in hands-on poc
do they actually see a demo is it more
of you know an offline presentation it's
more of a presentation we are there
boots on the ground um in the farms for
a period of time to make them see it's a
kind of a process uh
first we show them a poc and if they're
uh if they're choosing to enter us to
the farm we are there for a period of
time um
um you know working them up working
there operating the the tractors showing
them the technology and step by step
we're going back and they're they are
replacing us um in the
in the stand of um
managing the split of uh of tractors um
it's really important also to show the
technology to get them really close
to see how the robot is thinking how the
computer is thinking how is the
algorithm stinks um and to make the the
interface of the fleet management
very user-friendly and very similar to
other apps you know um and not making
you do a whole degree just to understand
how to operate those they're are defeat
and so once once you get introduced what
is sort of this and again this is coming
from my own personal passion and
curiosity for how humans around the
world are interacting with robots yeah
it's taking place
the first day the first run of an
autonomous vehicle that is sort of
changing the behavior of the landowner
the farmer
now with sort of the sim autonomous
machinery what is the reaction how do
people you know sort of when they talk
to your blue white robotics how do they
react to this immediate transition
that's happening it's sort of like this
binary zero to one
so um first of all we're trying to be as
good as first of all the the basic layer
of being as good as a human driver
so i think that the reaction in the
beginning is first of all to see the
safe side
so um people want to see that it stops
when it understand it there's some kind
of an obstacle in front of it if it's a
human or a vehicle so so of some sort
and then when we pass this
level um
they're looking to see if it's drive
accurately enough if it's in the middle
it's the implement that is connected to
the tractor is doing the job properly um
and you know sometimes the clients get
ins inside the tractor to see how it
works inside and it's a weird experience
in the beginning it was weird also for
me i can honestly say because you're
sitting inside a tractor and everything
just moves you know
everything um and it looks like there is
a ghost inside the tractor somebody is
moving this right right it's really uh
it's weird in the beginning and then
it's just fascinating to see everything
um
you know the the the tractor the robots
understand they feel it understand the
terrain it's understand that the
condition if it's day or night or uh
what is the what is the type of crop
um
all of this just get into the way um
it operates inside the field and you can
just see seamless work very efficient um
and as i said 24 7 which is uh super
important for for our customers to
to
get the best that they can
right so i imagine that still today most
food that we eat or is grown in outside
outside farms it's different debate on
when it will transition more to to
indoor but let's say you know still like
99 of the world is operating this way
i'm curious what is it going to take for
a company like blue robotics to get to
to expand globally so that everywhere in
the world it is both economical and also
self-sustaining in in other words how
far are we from sort of this
humanity-wise step function to the point
where our farms are completely
autonomous and we're able to increase
our crop yield universally
so um not so far i must say um because
the uh the autonomous gift it's just i
don't keep you don't need to buy
anything you don't need to change
anything in your farm
the the robot suits itself to the
environment
and the platform suit itself to to any
um
existent uh environment it's it's super
easy um well you know easy um easy to
get the robot inside the farm then the
algorithm learns the environment um and
then it just operates that so it's not
something we
we're seeing it already happening we're
seeing it already um
making the um the operation more
efficient more reliable
even more more
safe you don't want people to be inside
a tractor uh when it's spraying
chemicals uh it's not something people
should do in 21st century um
so even this that effect is uh is full
of with a good impact
um so it's something that we see already
today and if you are you asking me about
scale um we have our plan to scale um
and it's it's not something um you know
i see as a as a challenge that can be
uh that can be achieved it's just you
know we're going from one form to
another uh expanding um
getting to new environments learning how
the algorithm needs to uh improve itself
um learning how to to build a better uh
product
in a agile good agile method um
one step uh at a time
i love it i love it
what do you love most about what you do
where do you get your own sort of why
resolved
um i think that once you get into um
areas
in which you feel that the product or
technology that you're creating
is doing a direct impact on somebody's
life you're meeting the the clients and
you see wow what you did really affected
what right what i do and in my
day-to-day and it's not some i don't
know abstract story you tell but you
said it's really direct um it gives me
um
great pleasure uh this is my answer uh
when i ask myself what i do what i do um
and and for me personally it's also to
do something that is good for the world
um i don't know if it would sound a bit
of a cliche but um
it's really important for me to know
that um when i go to work
um and i put all of this effort in
something it should be something i
believe in and it should be something uh
that will help society um and
agriculture is a fascinating world as
you see um um in this world uh in the
last years i think it's a if we're
connecting it to the beginning of our um
of our talk then um
it's a it's a really a place where you
can bring technology a place that had
uh minimum technology you know 20 years
ago and you you saw you know it started
with uh um
some sensors uh getting into this uh
field and um
maybe some kind of management apps and
now you see the robots inside and
they're not there a lot to do in order
to make um
agriculture better to help us uh to help
it help us um
and uh yeah
i think it's a fascinating world i'm
happy to be in
well i'm just glad that the vice
president of product at blue white
robotics and it sounds like this company
is making a tremendous impact and is
really pushing pushing forward sort of
our own cognitive understanding of what
it means to have robots transformed our
agricultural environment and you know
sort of i guess the reason i was asking
about how drive how how these drivers
are now experiencing this autonomous
vehicle because it could also give an
interesting viewpoint on how we as
consumers are going to experience the
shift to autonomous vehicles on the
roads obviously different still from a
human to human perspective very very
interesting
but but i'm glad that you know in your
position you're you're going back
fundamentally to understanding that
there are significant implications of
the way these robots are interacting
with humans it's not a trivial idea and
so it requires a lot of thinking and
responsibility and mikhail thank you so
much for the time and the inspiration
best of luck with everything that you do
and i highly appreciate your work thank
you very much thank you